Anastasia
I want you back
Have dinner with me
Okay, fine. I'll have dinner with you
Because I'm hungry
Came to me quicker than that grey ?
Are you happy?
I've never been happier
He's changing
This time
No rules
No punishments
And
No more secrets
Do you know that girl Christian?
Do you think you the first woman
who's trying to save him?
It's not what he wants anymore
Your boyfriend has a, reputation
Do you wanna be caught
or have respect?
If something would've happen to you
I can never forgive myself
Tell me what you have that I don't
I want you back
I'm not very good at this
I never wanted
to try again.
Have dinner with me
Okay, fine. I'll have dinner with you
Because i'm hungry
But we are only talking and that is it
You came to me quicker than that Grey
Are you happy?
I've never been happier
Take 'em off
Your boyfriend has a reputation
Do you wanna be caught
or have respect?
Do you think you the first woman who's trying to save him?
He's changing
It's not what he wants anymore but what he needs
You just gonna stand there and gawking?
Yes
If something would happen to you
I can never forgive myself
Don't trade
I want you back
I had no idea what this was gonna become
I don't see how all this can work
You just gonna stand there and gawking?
Yes
You're the one Anastasia
This time
no rules
no punishments
And
no more secrets.
Do you think you the first woman who's trying to save him?